se nos pide identificar el porcentaje
cantidad y base en este problema y nos
preguntan 150 es 25% de qué número una
manera de hacer esto es multiplicar 25%
por un número 25% lo voy a poner en
amarillo 25% x
número y eso es igual
eso es igual a 150 150
aquí el porcentaje es fácil de
identificar aquí tenemos 25 % y ese va a
ser
el porcentaje y estamos multiplicando el
porcentaje por el número base así es que
aquí tenemos la base y tenemos que el
porcentaje multiplicado por la base es
igual a una cantidad esta de aquí es
entonces la cantidad y puedes resolver
esto mentalmente
básicamente lo que se está estableciendo
aquí es que 25 por ciento por un cierto
número es igual a 150 y para resolver
esto es mejor escribirlo como 0.25 que
es 25 por ciento por el número 0.25 por
el número esto tiene que ser igual a 150
y algo interesante por considerarse es
si este número tiene que ser mayor o
menor que 150 bien si sólo tomamos 25%
de ese número si sólo tomamos 25 entre
100 de ese número es decir tomamos un
cuarto de ese número porque eso es lo
que es 25 por ciento así es que ese
número tiene que ser mayor que 150 de
hecho tiene que ser 4 veces más
de 150 y para calcular entonces cuál es
el valor de dicho número
podemos dado que tenemos una ecuación
donde el lado izquierdo es igual al lado
derecho podemos multiplicar ambos lados
por un mismo número multiplicamos
entonces ambos lados por 4 consideramos
que aquí tenemos un valor que
multiplicamos por cuatro lo cual va a
ser igual a que multipliquemos 150 por 4
así que cuatro por punto 25 o 4 por 25
por ciento o 4 por un cuarto esto
simplemente es 1 por lo cual nuestro
número va a ser igual a 150 por 4 es
decir es igual a 600 y eso hace sentido
25 por ciento de 600 es 150 un cuarto de
600 es 150